none of these radical woke politically
correct people
seem all that happy to me i don't i
don't know about you i've never
seen not one of them a radical feminist
a radical leftist
you know any of the constituent parts
i've never seen one of them that seems
happy well
you know the proof of the pudding is in
the tasting perhaps that's because that
premise is wrong maybe the truth
actually will set you free and maybe
lies actually will delude you and make
your life worse
what's the problem with politically
correct speech
the problem with politically correct
speech is that it attempts
to transform reality by redefining words
so i think we can all agree at the most
basic level that's what pc does
it it redefines all of our terms and in
so doing it hopes to redefine reality
itself
the problem for conservatives though is
that it lays a trap
whereby basically any way you react to
pc
strengthens pc and i use the term pc you
could also use the term wokism or cancel
culture but
part of part of the issue is they change
all the words so we're talking about the
same broad phenomenon
obviously the one way conservatives can
react
to help pc along is just by giving in
right you just you use the new terms
you call bruce jenner she you whatever
you obliterate women's sports you
use all the kind of new jargon obviously
that gives them what they want
but then there's another group of
conservatives who say
no way i'm not going along with these
new standards you can't make me do it
i'm a free speech
absolutist right and i think a lot of us
have maybe used that kind of language in
the past
at various times but the problem here is
that the whole point of political
correctness
is to destroy the old standards right so
if you if you go along with that then
you're helping them to do that you're
destroying the old standards
but if you throw your hands in the air
and you say you know what i'm a free
speech absolutist
say whatever you want do whatever you
want i don't care i'm a purist right
you're also destroying the old standards
because now no one's so either way
pc gets what it's after and this is why
you know the phenomenon has has been in
our public consciousness probably about
30 years a little over 30 years or so
now it's been building for for more like
100 years
and it's why in that whole period of
time there is no shortage of
conservatives who said oh we're fighting
back against pc we pc has gone too crazy
donald trump basically staked his
2016 campaign on this issue of political
correctness
but we keep losing i mean this is the
first day of pride month we're now
first graders in the united states i
don't know about the uk it's probably
the same there too though
in the united states first graders are
being taught transgender ideology and
kellogg's cereal is telling them to pick
their own pronouns
so obviously we haven't done a great job
pushing back against bc and i think the
reason is
no one is willing to stand up and offer
a substantive vision
to defend the old standards does that
make political correctness conservatives
fault then
yeah basically you know chesterton one
of your fellow countrymen
had a great line where he said it is the
job of the liberal
to go about making mistakes and it is
the job of the conservative to make sure
that they never get corrected and i
think that's basically what
conservatives have been doing the past
30 or so years
part of this i think is because we don't
want to
offend anybody we want to be very nice
we're sort of generally
content that's why we're conservative
right that's why if
if we were not content if we thought
everything had to be ripped down we
would we would be radicals so we don't
we don't want to be offensive
uh really and then the other issue is a
lot of
conservatives basically
share the liberals central premises and
this is especially true in the united
states
because in the united states there is a
robust liberal tradition
and i mean even the classical sort of
liberal tradition um
i think it's tocqueville who made the
observation that americans behave like
conservatives
but they talk like liberals so the
language of liberty and individual
rights is all you know it's throughout
all of our
uh founding era and throughout really
all of our history but we don't talk a
whole lot about tradition we don't talk
a whole lot about order we don't talk a
whole lot
about law and order even i mean donald
trump you know kind of brought this back
in at the end of his presidency
but it's it takes the the second
position
to this idea of emancipating yourself
from everything this individual autonomy
and uh you know ultimately i think that
the only logical conclusion of that
is going to be this transgender ideology
and you see it actually
with the development of political
correctness first you're trying to
liberate yourself from social mores from
traditions from
religion then you're trying to liberate
yourself from the family structure you
saw this a lot with second wave feminism
and then ultimately you're trying to
liberate yourself from nature i mean
this is this is why i know a lot of
people believe that
transgenderism is kind of the opposite
of feminism right one
says women are real and need to be
protected and transgenderism says women
aren't real is just
men can actually become women too but
it's kind of that logical consequence
of this radical liberation which i think
is kind of the theme
that defines western modernity the last
500 or so years
and i i think we're kind of on the fumes
of that you know where
that only lasts so long as you've still
got some
animating principle and tradition in
your society but
goodness gracious it seems like that's
fallen down around us so i i just sort
of think either
we will defend old standards return to
tradition if you will
or or we're totally lost because the the
momentum of the radical left is
expressed in in political correctness
is just so great and it's only been
accelerated
in recent years if you're stuck in this
catch-22 though and it's essentially
impossible or
the situation that you've laid out is
very difficult semantically
for conservatives not to fall into one
of a number of holes or anybody that
isn't a leftist
to not fall into one of these holes you
don't need to be a conservative to
disagree with some of the semantic and
lexical games that are being played
yeah what do you do
this is the hard lesson i know a lot of
a lot of people aren't going to want to
hear this especially conservatives
we need to embrace a just and prudent
censorship now people are going to tune
out they're going to say michael yeah
that's the word
that's the word i knew i i was always
suspicious of that knolls fellow
you you know you're a sensor you're an
authoritarian okay
from the very beginning of our country
there have been whole swaths of speech
that you cannot engage in that are not
defended by the first amendment or our
broader free speech
tradition that includes fraud you know
you're not allowed to engage in fraud
that includes obscenity increasingly you
are actually encouraged to engage in
that but still we have laws on the books
against it
from the very beginning we were we were
throwing pornographers in prison for
obscenity as recently as 2009
it wasn't that long ago and that was at
the federal level
uh you you're not protected from
sedition in certain forms uh going back
to the earliest days of the country all
the way well into the 20th century
uh you're you're there are whole swaths
of speech that you're really not allowed
to engage in and the argument for that
by the way
is that certain speech undermines speech
actually i'll go back to chesterton who
has another great line
i think he's the most quoted man in the
history of the world chesterton says
there's a thought that stops thought
and that is the only thought that ought
to be stopped there and
you see this especially in some of the
woke pc
educational ideologies now a critical
race theory is the one that's very
popular but all the kind of critical
theory derivations
come out and they say there's no such
thing as objective truth
if you teach a child that there is no
such thing as objective truth
first of all it's completely incoherent
because you're making a claim of
objective truth that there is no such
thing as objective truth but
you're also undermining their education
you're not expanding the curriculum
you're not opening their minds
you're undermining the whole purpose of
education
which is grounded in the existence of
objective truth and higher faculties of
reason and all these sorts of things
same thing with fraud right if you can
abuse your speech to commit fraud you've
undermined speech because now speech
cannot be relied on to to
convey any sort of truth if you rely on
free speech protections to defend
obscenity
you're undermining free speech because
obscenity and all
sorts of licentiousness undermine our
own freedom the founding fathers were
very clear about this
the even you know some of the greatest
liberal writers in the classical liberal
tradition
will say you can't abuse your liberty to
the point of licentiousness
because then you've undermined your
liberty and the example i use on this is
a heroin addict right right now there's
a big push to legalize all sorts of
drugs
you see that from the derelicts on the
right on the left rather but you also
see it from some
more libertarian types on the right and
they'll say we gotta legalize drugs
because uh it's an unjust infringement
of your personal liberty for the
government to say otherwise
i think most of us have known drug
addicts in our lives right think of the
heroin addict who according to the
modern definition of liberty is the
freest
man in the world he is may as long as
he's got a buck in his pocket
he can go buy whatever he wants he can
shoot up oh the pinnacle of liberty the
whole purpose of the united states right
i don't think so i think actually we all
know that man is a slave he's a slave to
his lower
base passions and appetites and this is
because
man uniquely has intellect and will
and we actually have two kinds of will
we have the lower will which is
when we want to just stuff our face with
cookies or drugs or booze or whatever
and then we've got a higher will and
very often they're in conflict st
paul writes about this he says the
things that i want to do i don't do
and the things that i don't want to do i
do and
we all know what this means you've got
you know you're you're at the bar and
there's a cute chick at the end of the
bar and you say i know i don't
don't michael uh uh but the lower part
of you it's the little devil on your
shoulder right he says go
go down there so we've got the lower
will we've got the
rational higher will and the rational
higher will is mediating between the
lower will and the divine will which is
this
divine logic of the universe and we have
an intellect to help sort it all out
and aristotle says this is what makes us
a political animal
you know more so than any of the
gregarious animals
and the the expression of that is in our
speech
right that we're you know we don't just
grunt we don't just holler increasingly
we do actually in us congress and
elsewhere
but you know in our best selves we are
speaking we're persuading one another
we're using these symbols of words to
communicate things about objective
reality
and the moment that you compromise that
the moment you say there is no truth to
convey or you say you're not permitted
to say these
these things and you're going to muzzle
everybody up we've just come out of a
year where we've
literally been muzzled by these masks
everywhere then you are
cutting to the heart of what it means to
be human
and uh trying to liberate oneself from
from reality i think and i think that's
the whole purpose of it and it's why
the left has been so focused on this
sort of thing and unfortunately
the whole time so many conservatives
will look at at pc and wokism and
they'll say oh
it's just a distraction oh who cares who
cares
if you're going to call bruce jenner is
she or it's not
don't get hung up we ought to talk about
real things that matter like cutting
taxes a little bit more again
you say well you know i like tax cuts as
much as the next guy
but if you lose our relationship to
reality if you lose the whole culture
then tax cuts in a buck 50 will get you
a cup of coffee
the problem is semantic games can be
thrown away as well it's just semantics
it doesn't really matter
but as anyone that's read 1984 knows the
breadth of your language is directly
proportional to your ability to think
the thoughts that the language enables
and given that the quality of your life
depends on the quality of your thoughts
the quality of your thoughts depend on
the breadth of your language you
restrict the language
you restrict the thoughts you restrict
the life and
yeah as someone that adores speech and
language
and you know it's our language after all
michael although you guys deploy it as
best and as worst as you can sometimes
and we took all the use out i know we
did we made some alterations
kept hold of faucet though for some
reason we dispensed with faucet
uh but yeah you kept all of that but
yeah it it is
i understand why some people think that
it doesn't matter i understand why the
death by a thousand cuts the very very
slow erosion of language
seems like there are bigger problems out
there but it's so fundamental
to your ability to communicate with
other people but more importantly to
build
your ability to communicate with
yourself because if you can't
put the thoughts that are in your head
into words even for yourself
it's really the same as not being able
to think them because
the process of formulating thoughts into
words
it concretizes them in a way that
nothing else does otherwise it's just a
notion
right it's just this cloudy ephemeral
sort of wishy-washy thing and you can't
really grab a hold of it
you put it into words and it it takes
form and
slowly eroding away at this i think is
it's something that we should all be
really concerned about but it's it just
smacks massively of
conspiracy theory you know they're
coming for the words
and you think well it's it's hard to
find
a uh a narrative that puts across the
seriousness of it
without getting caught up sounding like
a
council culture devotee yourself
george orwell as you point out saw this
happening
60 years ago 70 years ago so
was he a conspiracy theorist aldous
huxley saw this happening around the
same time is he
a conspiracy theorist this has been
building for a very very long time and
just because
some people don't know anything about
history doesn't make the rest of us
conspiracy theorists and orwell was very
explicit he said
the purpose of limiting the lexicon is
to limit the range of thought exactly as
you say
and just think about what the words do
to you i mean you're so
precise and insightful here to say that
our
consciousness the way we view the world
comes out of the words that we use
one of the recent coinages out of the
the university
is this phrase justice involved
person that was my favorite that was my
favorite one
from yours it used to be young criminal
it's now justice involved youth
the justice involved youth you think
well hold on the one thing i know about
these kids the only thing i know
is that they are not involved in justice
they are actually involved in
injustice but they've totally flipped it
around and so if you're thinking of
young criminal
right what what image does that conjure
you say well okay some guys walking
maybe they've got some weapons maybe
they're terrorizing granny or something
okay
we gotta be a little harsh on them but
if someone is a justice involved youth
well it would be very wrong to punish
them
another one is a bum you know obama is
no longer a bum
or or now then they became a homeless
person
then they became unhoused the unhoused
people well
if they're unhoused that's that seems
like it's kind of my fault is it you
know i mean everybody else is housed
what is
what's happened to them that they've
been unhoused well no they've unhoused
themselves
usually through poor choices or through
mental illness or whatever
but we don't want to deal with any of
that we can never
permit there to be a moral explanation
or consequence for people's behavior
it's always got to be
somebody else's fault and if if you use
all that language
i guess the clearest one is just the
pronouns if you refer to caitlyn jenner
well even if you call him caitlyn that
conjures a certain image
but if you're if you refer to bruce you
know the future governor of california
if you refer to him as her and you say
she's this and she did this
and she won the decathlon you know some
years ago and she did this and she did
that
you're going to picture a woman and the
issue is
he is not a woman and he might very much
wish to be a woman and he might
even think that he is a woman but but he
isn't and the insistence
that that we participate in this lie
the insistence that we participate in a
delusion
is not only deeply offensive but it is
the end of society i mean if we
if we cannot agree on the most basic
aspects of reality
then we are not going to agree on
anything else and self-government will
not be possible
what it seems to me is that it's
compassion
poorly aimed that a lot of the
concessions that i make and and i'm sure
that you make with regards to your
language simply out of
the lack of askedness to be able to just
get into another argument
um a lot of those come from a place of
goodwill they come from the place that
look
i think that this is perhaps a good
concession to make or you you bring up
in the book that there's
some variants to do with people that are
um mentally disabled
and there are ways to remain factually
correct
which are emotively less uh
harsh right so those are ways that we
can play around with it but
how do you avoid that being a slippery
slope how do you stop it from
going from perhaps something which
most people would agree is offensive and
accurate to something which is less
offensive but still accurate
to something which is neither offensive
nor accurate
i i love this point by the way i it just
occurs to me i think
you are the first interviewer who has
read the book and it's not this is not
to knock
other interviewers who but we we've only
just recently sent
the book i mean it only went to the
printer about a week or so ago and we
sent out some advanced copy so i am very
honored thank you for reading the book
welcome to the uk michael
i know there really are people in the uk
they read you know they're very uh
sort of urbane there are two different
kinds of euphemisms right a euphemism
just sugarcoats harsh realities
with nice terms and pc is certainly a
form of euphemism because you're you're
redefining all these words but i'm not
just like i'm saying that i'm not
against all forms of censorship just
like i'm saying that i'm not against all
forms of ostracism or cancer culture
even
i'm also not against all euphemisms when
i
see a woman of a certain age i'm not
going to call her an old hag
i'm going to call her i'll call her a
woman of a certain age now that's
obviously a euphemism
but it's not a euphemism that
contradicts the reality
the thing is she is a woman of a certain
age but
technically every woman is technically
every single woman is but we all know
who we're talking about
we all know we're talking about older
women when we say that if uh
if i i say you know i'm gonna go uh
go hit the water closet or i'm gonna
i'll try to affect a little
britishness here or if i say i'm gonna
go you know if a woman says i'm gonna go
powder my nose
she may very well powder her nose she's
going to do other things but you just
don't want to conjure those images in
polite conversation okay that's fine
if to your example on mental illness or
people who are a bit
slower you know if you call them uh
a bit simple you know a bit slow even
the word [ __ ] was a euphemism for
for previous terms and because of the
euphemism treadmill you're gonna
you're going to regularly change those
those euphemisms it's just the way it
works
um that's perfectly fine it doesn't
that's not contradicting the reality
a handy capped person you know you we
went from [ __ ] to handicapped
okay there's that doesn't contradict the
reality it makes it a little less
harsh and offensive but then we went to
handy capable
what handy kate that implies that you've
got extra superpowers or something
that is contradicting the reality right
i mean it's not
no one wants to be offensive to anybody
but you don't you can't make me lie
you know you can't i'm not going to call
the woman of a certain age
a hot teenager you know she isn't she's
an older woman and
and so what pc is is getting us to do is
tricking us and pretending that oh this
is a very polite thing
but lies are not polite and i think one
of the
the premises of the modern left is that
lies are compassionate and the truth is
cruel if you go and you tell bruce
jenner that he's really a man and not a
woman
or especially when we hear about trans
youth we're hearing more and more about
trans youth because there is a social
contagion aspect to this
this cult as well but if you if you tell
a trans youth
um hey mister you you are not a woman
you actually you are a guy and i know
you're going through some
problems right now and i'm sure that's
very difficult and you got to work it
out but
just know this you are a man you're not
a woman
we would be told this is harsh this is
cruel this is going to make people more
depressed and anxious there's like
really no evidence of that but we'll be
we'll be told that
but i think it's very disrespectful to
lie to people and i think that if you
live in lies
you you're going to set yourself up for
a very bad life
and and one of the bits of evidence of
this by the way this is
totally just anecdotal this is not
scientific
none of these radical woke politically
correct people
seem all that happy to me i don't i
don't know about you i've never
seen not one of them a radical feminist
a radical leftist
you know any of the constituent parts
i've never seen one of them that seems
seems happy well you know the proof of
the pudding is in the tasting uh
perhaps that's because that premise is
wrong maybe the truth
actually will set you free that's that's
our old understanding of it
and maybe lies actually will delude you
and make your life worse
you've got this quote where you say no
revolution can succeed if it opposes
common sense
therefore the clever revolutionary must
transform the common sense
to accord with his vision i think that
really succinctly
explains the inversion that we're seeing
with language at the moment
are you familiar with a concept called
the retreat to the inner citadel
do you know this i don't actually let me
educate you
so this is hysteria this is from isaiah
berlin
and he says that when the natural road
toward human fulfillment is blocked
human beings retreat into themselves
become involved in themselves and try to
create inwardly
that world which some evil fate has
denied them externally
if you cannot obtain that from the world
which you really desire you must teach
yourself not to want it
if you cannot get what you want you must
teach yourself to want what you can get
this is a very frequent form of
spiritual retreat in depth into a kind
of
inner citadel in which you lock yourself
up against
all the fearful ills of the world so a
simple way to put that would be
if your legs wounded you could try to
treat the leg
if you cannot then you can cut off the
leg and announce that the desire for
legs is misguided and must be subdued
so basically if you can't win at a game
you stop playing you say that you never
cared about the game and you create your
own game with rules that you can more
easily win at
so this is something that i've been
trying to put in for years and a buddy
explained this to me
and it's a red pill that i can no longer
stop seeing so
um if people can't get a relationship to
work how many of them declare that all
monogamous relationships
are just restricting and they go
polyamorous or they can't gain status in
a meritocracy so they announce that the
system's rigged and they're gonna it
keeps people down and now they're gonna
gain state just by being a critic
of status structures at large or you
struggle to be popular and well liked so
you convince yourself that you're an
introvert or you find losing weight
difficult so you say
that losing weight has no bearing on
health and that any encouragement to
lose weight is an attack on your
identity
or you have trouble staying out of jail
so you say that jobs are for suckers and
you just
retreat to a life of crime all of these
different things these retreats to an
inner citadel to me seem to be
a big explanation for what we're seeing
with much of the language it's look
here are some things some levels of
discomfort that i've come up against in
the world
reality and my experience are not
meshing
as smoothly as i would like them to
therefore
my solution is to try and change the
rules of the game
so that they do at a social level to it
it reminds me a bit of
kurt vonnegut's harrison bergeron story
where
where another another terrific story
where the the last capable man
is being hunted down because this this
uh
what you would now call woke tyranny is
trying to
drag every single person down to take
away
excellence to utterly upend our our
traditional understanding of society
and say you know yeah my leg can't be
healed well yeah who needs legs legs or
legs are awful um people are very
wrapped up in this
themselves you know a man wrapped up in
himself makes a very small package
indeed
and one of the issues i suspect is that
uh people are thinking of themselves a
lot you know if you want to
break out of that if you want to kind of
re-engage with society and have a better
chance
at a flourishing life it's not that you
need to think
less of yourself it is that you need to
think of yourself
less where no one's asking you to think
less of yourself but
we are now told that we are not allowed
to tell the man who thinks he's a woman
that he's really a man because gosh you
know that's
it would be so awful for him it would be
so he he
just has this problem and so we all need
to go along with that
we're not allowed to say that it's
better to be married than
not to be married you know and going
back to our example at the bar
you know hitting the bar every night and
picking up the cute check well some
people just can't get married right that
that's too bad yeah people suffer
everybody suffers okay
you and i have suffered everybody
watching this right now has suffered
and the the fact of that is is not
a reason to deny that there is such a
such a thing as the good or the true
or the beautiful the fact that we don't
always get to attain it the fact that
not every kid gets a perfect sat score
is not an argument for doing away with
the sats
right it's an argument for hopefully
people can work a little harder and we
need to be nicer to people
maybe who can't you know succeed in a
certain way and we've got to bring them
in and help them flourish and
yeah sure i'm all for that but don't
don't destroy the the conception of
excellence don't destroy
the understanding of good and true and
beautiful and this is
this is something conservatives have
really fallen for because
when the left comes in and destroys the
old standards they'll say look
what you think is good i think is bad
what you think is true i think is false
what you think is beautiful i think is
ugly
and the the modern conservative response
to that is like well i guess you're
right man
you know i guess yeah no accounting for
taste
but that's pretty lame and gives away
the whole game to the left
the true response has to be you're wrong
you're we're right and you're wrong and
by the way if if you're right and we're
wrong you need to convince me of that
you need to make an argument that
persuades me but the radical
subjectivism
that we have all fallen into is what has
allowed these kooky theories to take
hold i mean
you uh referenced this point i made in
the book uh earlier on
which is that the revolutions need to
take control of the common sense
this is the insight that began
political correctness it began about 100
years ago
uh you know marx failed to instigate his
worldwide revolution
he wanted all the the lower classes
right the working class to unite across
the world
they were going to throw off their
shackles and the chains of industry and
didn't happen turns out that the working
class
has feels much less of a bond
to its fellow proletariat proletarians
than
it does to its fellow countrymen its
fellow parishioners it's fellow
members of their race it's phil whatever
the what whatever the the group is going
to be
and so antonio gramsci this brilliant
marxist theorist
and communist politician he said ah the
problem is
the conservatives have the common sense
they have the culture
and so what we need to do if we want the
revolution to succeed we need to go in
infiltrate all of these institutions
through a war of position
and then transform the common sense such
that
you know the workers who won't get on
board with our theories right now in the
factory
they will uh be so steeped in our
culture and our ideology that they will
naturally
follow us and uh you know it's hard to
deny
that the left has been fairly successful
at that over the last hundred years
my favorite quote that summarizes that
is the left won the culture war now
they're just driving around shooting the
survivors
which is just the most accurate thing it
really does seem to me like the left
really hate the working class at the
moment though do you get this sense
yeah there's a there is a clear disdain
and contempt
i mean you see this over the past year
with the
exaltation of our or dr fauci peace be
upon him and all the other
high priests of progressivism i mean
these are the the experts who know much
better
than the deplorable irredeemable
bitter clinging i mean these are the
words that just the democratic
presidential candidates and presidents
have used
to describe the lower classes uh also
known as
the the american people a huge huge
portion of the american people
over the past 10 years they hold them in
great contempt
and it's i think comes from an irony
that uh
the left purports to love humanity and
fight on behalf of humanity
and they're so focused on humanity they
they can't concern themselves with
actual humans
the humans really drive them nuts but
humanity they love
it's weird as well because the vast
majority of
immigrant populations of black and
ethnic minorities
in america are probably going to be
working class
but it seems like their label of ethnic
minority
has superseded their label of working
class so the culture provides them an
exit route out and kind of a safe space
within the leftist ideology is that
right
yes and that this was gramsci's
observation too he said p people
actually don't
really identify with their job or their
their economic status not anymore
anymore yeah i mean but but they they
they could identify much more with say
their religion their nationality their
race
their whatever um and and so
that that does give the left and out
it's why the the left has done very very
well
certainly with uh with black voters but
with other minorities too other
immigrant groups
uh is because they can really gin up
that kind of
uh grievance and resentment and where it
didn't exist before they'll they'll sort
of manufacture it
like they did through institutions like
the ford foundation and other other
groups in the 1970s
um you know even the the moniker
hispanic did not really exist you know
before about 50 years ago
the idea that someone in mexico and
brazil and peru and guatemala and spain
are all somehow the same thing is quite
offensive i think actually but
same thing with asian the idea that
chinese japanese vietnamese
indonesian all that somehow it's all
just the same
is offensive and silly but politically
it's very useful
and uh so that you know they've they've
un unfortunately
the left seems to understand politics
quite a bit better than we do
and and it's a point i make in the book
i think we
as conservatives tend to pat ourselves
on the back and we say
we understand reality so much but we
understand speech free speech oh we're
way
smarter about that than the left is but
the fact is we're not
they they understand it much better they
understand it's a role
in an apology much better and it's how
they've been able to manipulate it so
successfully
while we twiddle our thumbs i definitely
think they understand the delivery
mechanisms
better now everything that the left
creates is
slicker and sexier and cooler and i know
that you guys at the daily wire are
trying to slowly sort of claw your way
back into
the culture at the moment but it really
does feel like the left one the culture
war and now there's just
a few silos left over from the right
that are trying to sort of hold on
what about the destination for the pc
types then have they got an
end goal that they're trying to achieve
here does it ever stop
so i think it is a purely negative
campaign
i don't think that it is exactly like
we've got the traditional moral standard
which asserts that certain things are
good and true and beautiful and others
are not
and then we've got the pc standard and
that's going to assert certain things i
i just think the pc
version the leftist version is a is an
inversion
of the traditional it's just seeking to
destroy and it's why
leftists don't ever seem to really edify
anything right they just
the blm mostly peaceful protests left
rubble in it in their wake
right i mean it was and they actually
burned down the country uh this is true
of
antifa this is true of uh
of so much of the leftist political
action so the the only thing
if i were trying to be charitable to
toward the left
something i don't do very often but i'll
try i'll try um but if i were trying if
i were trying to give a charitable read
and in many ways that's what my book is
trying to do
i would say that the left is interested
in the most radical extreme
of liberation and the most radical
extreme of liberation
is self-undermining it destroys your
liberty because it requires you to
liberate yourself
from reality from nature
into uh this mad
mind another one of your countrymen john
milton i think described this quite well
in paradise lost where and actually he
described
your your discussion of you know the guy
who can't get his leg to work right he
says well i hate legs you know i don't
want it
when when satan is cast down into hell
he says well good who who needs heaven i
don't
the mind is its own place and it can
make a hell of heaven
and heaven a hell and of course it can't
you know i mean
the problem is that isn't heaven is
going to be heaven and hell is going to
be hell
and the moral order is going to be the
moral order but people can delude
themselves
a lot and it's it will lead to misery as
is happening right now
turning the bar stool upside down can
only last for so long though
you can't you can't create a foundation
upon
nothing so what i'm interested in you
know it's fascinating living through
this slow-motion car crash and kind of
watching it all unfold
but what i'm interested in is where this
continues
where this ends up and none of us are
clairvoyant but i still do think it's a
fascinating
thought experiment to go okay so just
roll the clock forward let's say that
everything becomes deconstructed and
this utopia
the utopia arrives what then
like if every if all of the
conservatives decided that they were
going to back off
what would be the end goal because
all of the groups that we're talking
about or whichever group they decide to
latch on to to use as the
vanguard of the next particular
political push forward
that then gets sliced up and sliced up
into increasingly finer and finer
slivers so it's not just
black people it's black feminists then
it's black feminists who are differently
abled then it's black feminists that are
differently abled that
like mexican food and then so on and so
forth you know it just continues to be
chopped and chopped up and you think
well that's self-defeating that's the
snake that eats its own tail
and inevitably all of those groups have
differing you see this with lgbtq
plus right you see yeah the t's don't
really have an awful lot to do with any
of the other groups that are in there
and the g's and the l's actually don't
have anything to do with each other
other than their mutual disdain for each
other because they don't care about each
other sexually
and then it's my interesting thought
experiment is where does it end up
you roll the clock forward what happens
then it ends up in the abolition of
humanity
and what what i mean by hate i hate to
say
yes yeah but i i think that's exactly
what it does
because it's it's an anti-social
ideology that says
we we are our only obligation
is toward our own uh selves and
ultimately even to our own
basest appetites and so it views social
relations
such as they are as merely contractual
or
predatory so you know the the
traditional understanding is that we
love one another we love our fellow man
we treat our neighbors
as ourselves and uh so when one loves
someone you are willing the good of the
other
i'm not just if i love you i'm not it's
not i'm not just gonna treat you as an
object from my personal pleasure
i'm actually maybe i'll have to
sacrifice man no greater love has a man
than to die for his friends
maybe i'll have to give you some tough
love if you're going in the wrong
direction but i'm really willing it for
you
but i think the modern radical vision of
it
is that other people are merely around
for our financial betterment
for our sexual pleasure for our personal
amusement
but these this deeper foundation of
societies is totally gone
and uh it actually another englishman
c.s lewis
describes this kind of demonic love in
the screw tape letters where
where he uh depicts this kind of love as
a desire to consume all your you know
the the uncle demon loves his nephew
demon because he wants to eat him you
know he wants to totally devour him so i
think
it ends there and then it it it it
breaks society so no longer is man the
social or political animal
but it also robs us of our speech
because if there is no such thing as
objective truth
and if in some cases we're literally
literally not allowed to speak you know
we're being
shut up and censored from speaking the
truth then
our essentially human quality is gone
too and so when
when i say that the the end game of this
radical leftism is the abolition of
humanity i mean anything that
distinguishes human beings from
animals from the beasts uh would be
taken away
our our social bonds and our ability to
to communicate reality to perceive truth
and
to communicate that that would be taken
away and so we'd be divvied up
into essentially a perfectly atomized
world
just individuals with no bond to anybody
else and we would be grunting
animals with sticks because we couldn't
persuade anybody of anything we wouldn't
speak
the same language we increasingly don't
speak the same language
so then politics becomes less a practice
of persuasion and
building consensus and and much more a
process of
imposing one's will and interest on on
another person or another group which
increasingly you are seeing that happen
and you're seeing the decline
of of uh deliberative government
and and you're just seeing a bunch of
yelling and screaming and violence in
the streets and that's uh
so my my bleak picture of that utopia is
uh it would
look a lot like warring tribes of
animals well you see this with the
eco movement at the moment right green
as alex epstein calls it is human racism
he says that it's such self-hatred of
the human race
and it's almost cool at the moment
within certain circles to talk about the
disdain
that you have a curse on the on the
earth destroying mother nature
as he calls it the uh perfect planet
hypothesis
that everything would be fine if only we
weren't here um
and yet in the same sentence many of
those people will have an overlapping
ideology
with people that want to completely
change the current way that the planet
is made up and the way that everybody's
preconceptions about how the world works
should operate and it seems as well
encouraging people to be mindful and
precise
of the language and the words that they
use makes sense to me but
demanding tolerance becomes undermined
when the people doing it
are insanely overbearing and intolerant
it's like punching someone in the face
in the name of peace
but but you know to give them their do
there's a very famous infamous essay on
this topic by herbert marcuzza who was
one of the
frankfurt school critical theorists who
then reappeared in the 1960s
as the father of the new left and he
wrote this essay called repressive
tolerance
and it's a diabolical little essay where
he says look
the current mainstream tolerance that we
have in the west
is very wicked and evil because it there
are certain things are off limits and
certain things are
censored and ostracized but the the
dominant
sort of western view is protected and
so what we need to do is go in and
correct this
and so a liberating tolerance according
to marcusa
would not tolerate conservatives right
would just censor conservatives
and encourage speech from leftists and
his argument is that the conservatives
are not tolerant
and so you can't coherently tolerate
intolerance and i i think he actually
makes a decent point uh not in the
particulars but on the broader principle
you cannot have any sort of
society that no matter how tolerant the
society is
that would undermine its own existence
you just can't do it it doesn't make any
sense and
even the great philosophers on
toleration talked about this john locke
who is the father of liberalism for
goodness sakes he wrote in the letter
concerning toleration
he said well look we've got to tolerate
everybody and we've got to be really
nice and tolerant
except for atheists we should never
tolerate atheists those guys man they'll
because of course doesn't that
align with what you suggested at the
very beginning that there needs to be
a concession there does need to be a
small
small amount of this that's that's
permitted there there does yes i mean
there there needs to
we want to have a nice broad society we
want to be able to
you know perceive the truth but that is
the point you know let's let's not
the purpose of of keeping an open mind
is not so that it can stay open forever
and your brain falls out the purpose of
having an open mind
is to close it again around truth that
you have perceived
a good line from this uh comes from bill
buckley he was quoting actually a
liberal
president of yale university and he said
skepticism has utility
only when it leads to conviction you've
got to ultimately
believe in certain things and buckley
actually as mainstream a conservative as
it gets
he described himself as an
epistemological optimist
he said look i think you know he and he
even made fun of what a silly phrase
that is and he said you know i believe
a typical bill buckley way uses a 20
word to describe a very simple concept
he said i believe that some things are
true we know them to be true and we
don't need to relitigate them every five
seconds you know
there's certain premises that our
society is going to to embrace and so
he said for instance that we don't uh we
don't need to
constantly be uh entertaining the ideas
of the nazi or the communist
these are these are bad ideas they're
antithetical to our
civilization and so it we're done with
that uh and your point is so perceptive
on the self-hatred involved here there
is there is no
country or no civilization ever in the
history of the world as self-hating
as ours is i mean we're the only we're
the only people on earth
who are constantly prattling and
babbling on and on about how terrible we
are and how
as though we and people in the west
pretend that we invented slavery
slay we're the only civilization in
history that has abolished slavery
where slavery still exists in virtually
every other part of the world
except for in the west and yet we
pretend that we're unique
we i suppose we are unique in the fact
that we abolished it we pretend that
we're the only racist
civilization we're the least racist
civilization in history
every other country in the world is
extraordinarily racist uh
not us we take people in from all sorts
of backgrounds and things like that
but i i suspect a lot of this comes down
to a very
personal point which is that people
hate themselves we've gotten to a point
in society where
people really seem to hate themselves
and they say that
their mankind is overpopulating the
earth
now none of these people by the way who
talk about overpopulation ever want to
take themselves out of the population
you know it's always somebody else comes
out but
you know we we kill our children through
abortion a million a year in the united
states
we are trying to convince people not to
have children quite as much whether for
ecological or social reasons this is why
the birth rate has plummeted i mean it's
now at a historic low but
you could say that every single year we
seem to hit a new historic low
we want to give away territories seed
them back to conquered peoples it's
it's a bizarre thing and i i suspect
there's a religious component here as
well you know cardinal manning has a
good line he says
all human conflict is ultimately
theological
cult and culture come from the same root
word and i suspect a little bit of that
self-hatred
reflects a hatred of god and whose image
we are made and it's it's why
there seems to be such a a bizarre
religious
component to all of these uh these
various ideologies
notably transgenderism which which
adopts a gnostic view of human nature
the idea that that our bodies have
nothing to do with who we really are
you know that we're purely soul in in
contravention of the
the true understanding of our self which
is that we're body and soul put together
it's curious to me that the radical left
simultaneously advances these two
apparently opposite views one that we're
just meat puppets just synapses firing
off in our brain all our hopes and joys
are illusions
the materialist view and then the other
that our bodies have nothing to do with
who we are and
you know a man can be a woman if he
really feels that way the gnostic view
they're they're opposites but they both
contradict the traditional view and i
think actually that's a good
example of the way that political
correctness works it doesn't matter what
argument they're putting out at any
given moment
as long as they destroy the traditional
understanding of the society
talking about the big picture in the
globe at large i often think about this
i read a lot of existential risk which
just in case the current situation
wasn't cataclysmic enough it makes it
feel even worse
and what i'm thinking is how much
of the smartest minds of our
generation's time has been taken up
debating stupid [ __ ]
over the last five to ten years or so
literally the some of the best brains on
the planet have had
the lion's share of their online time
spent debating whether men and men and
women and women are not
and right the concern is i can't quite
put my finger on it
the debates around semantics are
immediately visible
you can see the unfolding
of all of the consequences of at least
the speech itself not the second order
third order effect of what happens due
to the speech
we can at least see the argument on its
own merits right
but what you can't see is what happens
down the line from that what is the
world that we could have had if we
hadn't got caught up
with this or that or the other and it
seems like um
you look at the the wuhan lab leak uh
flip-flop from facebook that's occurred
recently right
that's a prime example of a semantic
game being played
this type of speech is not allowed okay
so the speech is obvious it's very
easily defined and it's immediate you
can shut that down
but when the facts start to catch up to
the narrative
eight months twelve months later you
think okay so actually what we did was
we punished people who had
truth as opposed to people that had
falsehood i'm not sure if it's true it
might be it's purported it's possible it
might be probable but you know at least
it should have been permitted
and you think of course this um
asymmetry
in the pace at which arguments are
visible
i think lends um unfair weight
toward people that want to play semantic
games as opposed to people that want to
root what they're doing in reality
because reality is always going to move
more slowly the consequences are always
going to be seen down the line
does that make sense it does make sense
and i i it
brings to mind that meme that shows up
where someone will say you know
this would be the world if so and so had
never been born and it's futuristic and
it's you know
everyone's in flying cars and everything
you know if only dr fauci stopped
speaking then you know this would
usually
usually they come from the left but
right then we'd all be in this
very advanced civilization i think
that's true however
the thing we've got to grapple with is
is where the fault lies in ourselves and
you know i'm i'm all for owning the libs
and dunking on the left when they're
going crazy which is
all the time but we can't just leave it
there i mean the fact is
that the left has developed its ideas in
a in a certain culture and so
when we say we want to defend the west
against the predations of the radical
left well the radical left arose out of
the
out of the west right i mean the left
even the term the left
goes back to the french revolution and
the french revolution was it was a
historic
tragedy but that came from somewhere too
and so
one does wonder and this this thesis has
been advanced in recent years by people
like patrick dineen
and why liberalism failed and other
writers and thinkers too
that that something went wrong somewhere
along the way we somehow lost the thread
somewhere along the way i mean the
oswald spengler's book now it's a
not really read quite as much but you
know 60 70 years ago has read quite a
bit
the decline of the west maps out
why the west has to go into decline
because of the
circumstances that have arisen from
within it and so i think it's very
frustrating i wish that we didn't have
to spend all this time saying that men
are men and women are women and babies
or babies and
there is such a thing as truth or
whatever but
maybe the reason for that does not lie
in
uh you know just only in herbert marcus
50 years ago or only in antonio gramsci
are only in karl marx but actually goes
back
even further than that where where did
we lose this thread
because there there are you know major
ideas at play and ideas obviously do
have consequences and uh
i just think if we try to fix the
problem solely based on you know
the clinton administration to the
present uh we're not we're not going to
get very far and
one of the things i've tried to point
out in this book is that political
correctness which seems like it's 30
years old
it's at least 100 years old and so the
modern radicalism goes back so so far
where are we going to find those answers
are we going to find it in science
you know capital s trademark over the e
so many of our debates now are so
reductive and shallow over
over gender or babies right they'll say
uh a baby
should not be killed because he has
unique dna
they say okay okay sure yeah i agree
that's true he's obviously a distinct
entity but plenty of things have unique
dna why should i not
kill the baby well because the baby's a
human being why shouldn't we kill human
beings
well because you know they can they
they're self-conscious they say well no
babe a baby's not a baby's
completely unconscious basically or i
mean even even a newborn baby is not
a walking talkie the reason we do it is
because humans have dignity
because they're made in the image of god
because they have souls and they
they you know are this very dignified
being well now
we've left the realm of science now
haven't we now we're in the realm
of philosophy and and religion and uh
we're very uncomfortable talking about
those things the way that we talk in the
west
today about philosophy and religion is
like
like an anthropological exhibit we talk
about it like we're in a museum and we
say
look here's philosophy over it people
used to think this then they thought
oh look at religion those look at these
grunting idiots used to think whatever
yeah
we don't treat these things as though
they we don't treat aristotle as though
he tells us something about the way
we're living today
we don't treat thomas aquinas for that
matter as though he has something to say
about the way we're living today
it's not our understanding of philosophy
and religion is not a living one
and so our civilization is not a living
one it's
it's a dying one and uh that's that's a
sad fact
i wonder how much of the
difference between how the uk and
america
at the moment culturally is split that's
not to say that there aren't
sort of progressive crazy policies and
stuff like that over here but
it really is orders of magnitude
different to where it is with you guys
how much of that do you think is because
your country
is based in a history which is only a
quarter of a million year old
like we can roll back yeah fair enough
vikings and normans and
so on and so forth were hardly sort of
genetic purists ourselves we are
amalgamation of a lot of different
things but you know there's castles in
the uk that are thousands of years old
and we can track that history back
i wonder whether the um the roots lie
sufficiently deep
with regards to tradition over here that
there are more um
tangible artifices that people can grab
onto
do you know what i mean that there's
there's there's a genuine sense of
history
whereas for america you know the history
very much still
is unfolding there is still a lot to be
discovered about what the country
is it just seems unfortunate that it's
occurred at a time
where the free movement of information
has enabled some bad actors to weaponize
that
i think your point is totally right
because when you even say what is the
founding story of america you could get
different answers is it the pilgrims i
tend to trace it i suppose to the
pilgrims
is it the settlers in virginia and
jamestown
some people would say that is it 1776
that was the very beginning nothing
happened before that
i don't think that's quite fair that's a
little shallow is it the wild wild west
well it might be a lot of people trace
it to that as well
or is it the story we're increasingly
told that we're a nation of immigrants
and really america begins at ellis
island
a lot of people want to believe that
well depending on which story you pick
you're gonna have a very very different
understanding
of america and they all seem equally
plausible because the country
is not particularly old add to this the
problem of totally
open borders which effectively is what
we have today and you have a country
with with historic levels of immigrants
who have not assimilated in any way
america always did a
basically a good job about assimilating
its immigrants and then when it wasn't
able to do that it would restrict
immigration and this
gave us a relatively stable society but
now that's gone and so
if you if you have a country and you
uh at the corporate and governmental
level try to replace and undermine its
institutions and traditions
and then that you actually change the
people of the country such that now a
huge something like one-fifth of the
country was not born here and does not
really know particularly much about the
country well then you're going to get a
different country you know
and uh the uk has probably survived a
little bit better because of that weight
of history um and you see it especially
at the religious level you see this
in the the catholic protestant split you
know
the idea when martin luther was nailing
his theses to the
to the church door was that finally we
were going to have a recovery of truth
after the absolute corruption of of
the catholic church and the rome the
roman hierarchy
and what happened did you get a
reformation no you didn't get a
reformation
did you get a new singular church to
challenge the catholic church
no you got 30 000 churches because there
was that
that crack you know and and the catholic
church despite its many many
problems and scandals that continue to
go on and have gone on for a long time
it remains i think because of its divine
institution
but also without question because of its
history
because of its tradition heller bellock
has a good line on it
he says that you know he has to take it
as a matter of faith that the catholic
church is divinely instituted
but for non-believers and evidence of
its divine institution
is that no other institution conducted
with such navish imbecility
would have lasted a fortnight and this
is uh certainly true and it's true
of other places with with a long history
but what are we doing now especially in
this country to our history
we're tearing down all the statues and
and i think it's why the left focus is
on language
and and of course on our national memory
tear down washington
tear down jefferson when trump said that
would happen four years ago everyone
laughed at him
within 18 months they were pulling down
those statues and where does it go from
here
did you see that summer and other
seasons have been added to a list of
triggering terms
did you see this i i did see this
because
you see summer in one hemisphere yeah
may not be summer in another house let
me let me read this out for the people
that haven't seen it so this is
laura lara hogan adds summer and other
seasons to list of triggering terms
twitter's state this is a think tank for
the nation's brightest minds took a hit
once again
when lara hogan announced that she will
no longer use the word summer
because it may be triggered for some
according to her twitter profile lara
hogan is the founder and leadership
coach at
wherewithal the company website states
that hogan spent a decade growing
emerging leaders as the vp of
engineering at kickstarter
and an engineering director at etsy so
she makes nice posters and stuff like
that
uh hogan's full tweet reads a teeny tiny
inclusive language thing i've tried to
get better at this past year
is avoiding northern hemisphere specific
seasonal language
like instead of this summer i say the
months i mean
or a q3 because it might be that season
for me
but not that season for everybody
joining the call
for the season sensitive lexicon are
chipmunks and squirrels notorious for
the preferring
of humorous summer season over the snow
laden winters
q3 time and the living is easy
i don't think anyone's going to be
singing that do you know i love that she
suggested
q3 because what she thinks she's doing
is this very liberal impulse to take
away all considerations of particularity
of time and of space she's going to take
away you know
yes you're right it's when it's summer
here it's not somewhere somewhere else
she's gonna take that away i'm no longer
a citizen of this country or that
country i'm no longer
i'm in the the realm of the universal
okay
but she's using terms that are used
almost exclusively by neo-liberal elites
the idea of q3 what are we doing
now we're we're going to the sales
report for this season
yeah finally we're going to adopt the
much more inclusive language of a
mckinsey associate or someone at goldman
sachs yeah okay
sure i mean but but they they do this so
very often
you see now you know there's a move
against the american flag in the united
states a lot of the left will protest
the flag
on football fields or they'll take it
off of clothing or they'll
say it's a symbol of oppression but they
will wave the blm flag or the pride flag
especially now where i guess we're in
pride month pretty soon we'll have pride
year it's just going to be 12 12 months
of the year
and i think the reason for this in part
is because the american flag
is particular it it's it exists in a
place
it exists in a time it has certain
people it's got the
mountains and you know the various seas
but the pride flag is universal it
applies to everybody it makes imperial
claims this is why i think they're now
flying it
on embassies around the world uh the
american flag makes no claim
on someone in iran or the on the iranian
society the pride flag does blm the same
thing it just
describes this worldwide phenomenon of
the oppression of black people at the
hands of white people
and so that that flies around too they
want to
to uh in the name of liberty and
tolerance talk in this these universal
universal citizens yes that's exactly
what i have in my head
but the irony is it's as imperialistic
as anything it's actually more
imperialistic than the national claims
which are at least somewhat modest
they're at least bounded but even that
even now our nation is not bounded
because the borders are totally open
yeah i couldn't believe that you just
think that if you say good day to
someone is that
it's night time somewhere if you say
good morning it's evening time somewhere
i don't know man i don't know i am i
can't work out if we're closer to 1984
or a brave new world
it feels like some awful love child
of both so i think it's brave new world
i agree
yes idiot but it's not a love child like
50 50. no you know
sometime in the future they're going to
figure out how to engineer our dna
so we're only like 10 this guy and 30
this guy and
disc or whatever i think it's about 10
george orwell
specifically because of the language
focus of the radicals
but i think it's about 90 percent uh
huxley because huxley and huxley
actually made this point to orwell
because huxley was orwell's teaching
french teacher french teacher right yes
i think so
and so read the book read the book
michael yeah that's right yeah
truly i'm i'm so honored uh because
you've read the book now probably more
recently than i have so you could
probably tell me things about the
yeah maybe but yes huxley was was uh
orwell's french teacher
and he said you know george your your
dystopia is fine the language stuff is
good
but you think that the totalitarian
government is going to rule with an iron
fist
and it's going to you know take away all
people's sorts of pleasures and
but no actually what's going to happen
is
the the totalitarian government is going
to rule by
by playing to people's pleasures by
getting people so
drugged up on actual drugs by getting
people so
over sexed with casual non-committed
sex that they're totally outside of
their faculties of reason
and they're they're susceptible to being
controlled and when you look around our
society today
worst opioid crisis we've ever seen uh
you know marriage rates in the doldrums
but people having creepy sex you know
all over the place doing all sorts of
things
with any number of people and and that
being normalized uh
we're seeing that and we're seeing the
the idea normalized that any sort of
sacrifice any sort of burden
any sort of suffering is wicked and evil
and has to be overcome
so that we can just pursue our passion
you do
you don't yuck my yum this kind of
language i mean that's the language
of huxley's world state that is not the
language
of of orwell's big brother even if you
think about what
social media is doing right it's an
internal it's a
systemic rather than exogenous way to
manipulate the chemicals that you've got
in your body
immediate guilt-free pleasure uh the
same goes from
amazon you know you can amazon prime
yourself a
lovely new item that will give you that
hit while you doordash or deliver
a michelin star meal while you sit on
the couch and watch
million dollar produce tv shows on
netflix it's
it really is um yeah for all of human
history we've had problems of scarcity
right and now our problems are problems
of abundance
and i think you're right i think that
1984
might have happened if technology hadn't
enabled brave new world
without the technology i don't think the
brave new world can happen because
you re it requires such sophisticated
coordination it requires
um a degree of siloing of information
whilst also free
free communication across that and the
levels of
comfort and convenience that are
required in order to enact a brave new
world you need to have it here's the
thing right so i think about this to do
with existential crises all the time
how luxurious of a position it is to
have an existential crisis
because the only way that you can get to
that situation is if the bottom levels
of maslow's hierarchy of needs have all
been sorted
so much like if you if you're worried
about where the next meal is coming from
you don't have the luxury to concern
yourself about whether
you are contributing to your own highest
good within the world right
um so yes brave new world i'm i'm i'm
with you on that 9010 it's a language
from
1984 and everything else from brave new
world except for the soma
which was still yet to get except for
the soma although i don't i guess
oxycontin or something is the soma now
and i
i think that this issue of that
existential on we
people who work a lot don't have
existential on we
because they're busy working they have
they have needs to meet
and and beyond that by the way it's not
even just that we don't work enough or
we're all telecommuting or something
it's uh because there are plenty of
people who can't telecommute i mean this
was one of the arguments
uh for the lockdowns as all the genius
experts said oh no you can work on zoom
and i said oh right you none of you know
people who work physical jobs so you
don't you think that everybody can just
telecommute in on zoom
actually believe it or not there's some
people who do real things in real ways
so you need your plumbing fixing via
zoom yeah exactly
that's right yeah yeah that's right get
the electrician in on zoom it's not
gonna work very well
um so yes you've got this problem of of
abundance
and the the chemical aspect of social
media is is pretty clear too
the one that i get sucked into is
twitter i'm on twitter a lot i'm just
the one
i don't do facebook as much i don't do
instagram but twitter i do
and i was talking to a friend of mine he
said why are you on twitter so much
and just came out of me i said because i
don't want to look at porn
so i don't if i don't want to look at
porn i still want to get the same sort
of you know
pleasure of oxytocin whatever and so now
instead i'm just getting sort of
political
you know rage tweets or something but
everybody seems to be hooked on these
things and
for a lot of people i suppose it it is
literally porn right it's not even just
which is which is this other issue of uh
of abundance right i mean truly that
there you know if you can think of it
there's a porn for it
and i think it's why you're seeing a
reaction among younger conservatives you
know there was a big debate that busted
out
um in partaking in some ways of the pc
debate because we do have laws against
obscenity and yet they don't really seem
to be enforced very much with porn
and the debate to ban porn or not or to
regulate porn
you would imagine it would be the old
fuddy duddies or against porn
and the young you know rap scallions are
for porn but actually it was totally
reversed
the people defending porn were the
boomers the boomers who were using this
kind of
pseudo-quasi language of the 80s and 90s
and saying oh well you know if it feels
good do it and the younger people
who grew up on this stuff who i think
that the median age of of porn exposure
for boys is like 11 years old or
something
and they were saying no man this is
really bad stuff it's kind of messed me
up it's hard to work through
like how are we not regulating this and
uh you know that they are obviously much
more in tune
with political reality than these p then
these throw your hands up conservatives
who get rid of all the standards i'm so
glad i don't know
by what quirk of this version of the
simulation i managed to avoid a porn
addiction
but i'm so glad that that's not one of
you know of all of the vices and
and odd quirks and behavioral problems
that i've managed to
sidestep through life i'm really glad
that porn addiction isn't one of them
because it's so inconvenient
and i suppose it's it's just available
all the time but you know part of it
might just be
that if you're a millennial you've kind
of just missed it or you know maybe it
was it was still there i guess when we
were kids but
but you know still think you're right
dial up internet but
but think about if you're a zoomer right
think about if you're a kid who right
now is 18 years old or something
you have had some kind of high speed
device in your hand
from the time you were like three and
and so
your your brain just isn't built for
that and and it's
you know i think it also gets a little
bit to competing
theories of the mind you know there's
this one theory of the mind which is
that our mind is like a
a steam engine or something you know and
we've got and
we've got to just let it out we don't
want to repress anything we've just
gotta
if you blow off a little steam you'll
you'll feel great and then you can go on
you said that sorry to interject there
you said that this
aligned with the technologies of the day
right you kind of
had these different sections who was it
that was the steam
thing was that so so coincidentally
you've got sort of freud coming up
around the same time as the steam engine
right and
so freud is you know and freudianism
kind of leads to this idea that you
shouldn't
you've got all these repressed desires
and feelings and
thoughts and you've got to just sort of
let them out and and then you'll have a
much healthier society and and
and you then see this expressed in the
kind of kooky theories of guys like
wilhelm reich
who who believed that uh the the life
force the life energy was something
called the orgone this esoteric
particle and the the cause of war and
cancer and death and everything
was uh a lack of orgasms and so a little
bit more masturbation fixes a lot of
problems michael
yes no i mean this is truly what what
the left is saying now and you'll you'll
see it being taught in kids cartoons
they'll say you know it's perfectly
healthy it's totally right
to uh in the words of woody allen have
sex with someone you love
alone in a room you know you're the one
person you know you love
it's perfectly good that it's very
healthy you've got to do that during the
lockdown the new york city
health department was saying oh yeah you
can't hook up right now but you've
basically
you've got to go you know turn the
blinds down and have fun with yourself
whenever you can but this is actually
the opposite of healthy right
the traditional view is that virtues
and vices are habits and the more you do
them
the more you do them so you i mean you
make this point where you say i'm glad i
never developed
a porn addiction well i suspect part of
the reason you didn't is because
when we grew up it was you know it just
wasn't quite as available but if
if you had you know it had a device in
your hand at three years old and and you
were just doing this constantly
it would be very difficult to break that
switch i
[Laughter]
i mean this sort of you know i think
people are beginning
to recognize this a little bit more
especially as we as we become more
digitized
as we live more of our lives virtually
as we are zooming in to our friends and
our work and our parties and things
we realize as as the language of
universalism has taken over the language
of nation or country
we're beginning to realize wait a second
i'm a i do have a body
i am in time and space i know i'm told
that my identity has nothing to do with
my body
but i think maybe i do and you know i
think it's why jordan peterson
has become so popular and resonates so
well as he says hey
clean your room the things you do
actually actually do matter
and one of the really insidious aspects
of political correctness
is that political correctness takes old
moral codes
and replaces them with new speech codes
so it matters less and less and less
what you do
and more and more and more what you say
it's this you know we've kind of created
this
this prison of our own minds and that
that way lies madness
casting off the wisdom of old times is
so dangerous there's this quote from
donald nuth which i adore
and he says tradition is a set of
solutions for which we have forgotten
the problems
so good and yet when you have collapse
of grand narratives
and the lack of religiosity
you have the changes with regards to the
way that family structures
are accepted and so on and so forth it
doesn't just didn't surprise me
that you have this like there is again
to use the bar stool analogy it's been
upended and now it's sat in some stats
some sand and
there's nothing there's as soon as you
start to pull away at the traditions of
the past
there isn't anything to hold on to it
and this is coming from someone i'm
from a very salt of the earth normal
northern town
in the uk all of this sort of stuff
wouldn't come to us in terms of culture
wars
and yet i'm seeing now even somewhere
that is fairly traditional
i'm seeing this hearkening back this
desire for people to have their older
ways
a little bit more and um yeah man it's
it's
the bifurcating that you're seeing as
well with regards to how sort of people
are living their lives
but again as you brought up there um
first we make our habits then our habits
make us right
you can tell anybody that you want you
can do what you want you can eat the ice
cream
you can but when the diabetes comes for
you
in in 10 years time reality will
end up winning because reality doesn't
stop and
if your language and the lexical
manipulation is malleable
that's going to fold around reality as
it comes in okay so now
diabetes is what like an accepted side
effect of you eating whatever you want
because you shouldn't be told that
you're supposed to diet
that doesn't seem like a very healthy
way to go through things but
because the effects of a semantic gamer
immediate
and the consequences of a semantic game
are delayed
we've come we've got to it i've done it
uh that's what it is i think that plays
a big part in it you have these lagging
measures
that occur down the line but you have
the lead measures that happen during the
argument
and those are the ones that people are
playing about with at the moment but
as douglas murray says when the
barbarians are at the door we'll be
debating about what gender they are
if you don't focus on the here and now
with
the future the consequences of the
future in mind
you're going to end up with a future
that you really really don't want to
live in
we do and we we also have to acknowledge
something that the left gets right
and and the diabetes example is a very
good one
people's private decisions and private
behaviors
have public and therefore political
consequences public and political or
synonyms
now the left uses this they'll say look
you know we
we ought to be able to tell you whether
you can smoke or not because we're going
to pay for your health care
and we've got this federal health care
program city health care program and so
we ought to be able to tell you whether
you can smoke or not you say okay
i actually i don't want you to tell me
whether i can have my nightly cigar
but i do understand the logic here and
conservatives well obviously we want to
have some sort of a private sphere we
want
certainly protections for the family for
local local government local community
uh it is it is the case that if you have
a country
of vicious people if you have a country
that just engages in every vice under
the sun
and they are allergic to virtue
then it doesn't matter how nice your
constitution looks doesn't matter how
beautiful your supreme court building is
you're going to have a vicious country
that your private life
will have that public effect and this is
why you know i i think the collapse of
religion any kind of
traditional understanding of religion is
so bad here what you've seen actually is
as as religion has fallen apart right
and religion entails
that every time i commit a sin at least
my religion because i'm catholic
every time i commit a sin i've got to
take note of it i've got to count it
i've got to think of the circumstances i
have to go into a little black box
and tell a man in a color what i did to
receive that absolution from god
yes yeah not not him no i mean it's
really
anxiety-induced how many times have i
gone to confession a zillion times and
every time i still think oh gosh
he's gonna i did this horrible thing oh
i did it again too you know
and uh but i know that i'm i'm
answerable in my most
private moments in my most private
thoughts even if i break it even if i
fall short as we all do i know that i i
am answerable here
in the public but for the people who say
okay i'm done with religion
often you'll hear i'm spiritual but not
religious you know it just
usually means i'm not that interested in
god but i'm very interested in me you
know i think i'm a pretty interesting
chap
uh so that if you've got that idea
or even the idea that you know a private
confession is sufficient
or you know if you just think about
something that's fine c.s lewis makes
fun of this idea too
then there's really no accountability
for what you do in private and when
there's no accountability whatsoever
don't be surprised when that bleeds out
into the public
i've never realized the symbolic nature
of going through that process
in church i've never realized i've never
realized that but it makes a lot of
sense it reduces the lag
between the semantic game or the thought
or
the immediate action and it creates a
break point in between that perhaps
being instantiated as
a first we make a habit then i have it
to make us the repetition of that is
going to be much harder if every time
that you go back
and you do go to confession you're like
what this again this same michael
again you know so talking about social
media have you been watching what
stephen crowder
has been getting up to recently you know
i i'm i've been friends with stephen for
years and uh whenever he texts me i sort
of think like uh
what have you done now what did he do
now what did he do this time
what's he in trouble for and yes i mean
they are gunning for him i think in a
special way
because they can go after him on the
jokes and they can say the jokes were
too far
and because he's so mainstream i think
he may be the most mainstream
conservative that big tech has really
gone after
what do you think we've got to learn
from his situation at the moment
well i i love i mean the man has cajones
of steel
i he he may be a complete lunatic he's
so
he's got such brass culions you know
um i mean we have seen this guy be
waterboarded for a very long time
he is he's done all sorts of crazy
things that that most people would not
do
and he stood up to big tech and he and
he will not uh
bow down and i think the point that he
and i were discussing this the other day
you go after alex jones oh well alex
jones he's just a kooky far right guy
turns out he
actually appears to have been right
about everything you learn about the
frogs and yeah i mean
but uh you know well alex jones he's a
fringe figure okay you go after him you
go after gavin mcginnis gavin mcguinness
founded the proud boy he's very funny
comedian
uh but no he his jokes they went too far
okay you got to get rid of gavin
mcginnis
now you're going after steven crowd i
mean stephen crowder i think he has the
largest
online following of any conservative
basically certainly in the top three
if you go after and you take him out
they can take out any one of us and i
think that's really what this is about
um and i give them a lot of credit you
know i sometimes think if the
if the big tech oligarchs have not gone
after you at all
it means you're doing something wrong it
means that you know you're
when i think of the really squishy
conservative types you know the ones who
write for the atlantic and the
washington post and
go on msnbc or whatever
i i realize they're actually worse than
the left because the left is being
honestly dishonest right the left is
telling you what it what it believes and
all the
ghastly things it wants to do but these
guys
exist to legitimize
the the leftist the liberal
establishment their their role
is to act as a court jester in the
kingdom of liberalism
and uh so whenever you have an actual
conservative raising actual questions
that might seriously threaten the left
well they can't tolerate that you're not
going to get your cnn invitation
and more likely they're going to try to
boot you off like they're doing to
crowder the interesting thing
with talking about gavin mcguinness and
uh alex jones
is that although those guys had huge
especially alex right like a
terrifyingly big audience
and he's still holding on to it you know
he's broadcasting every day for
ridiculous numbers of hours even more
than you guys
it it certainly does feel like once
someone is pulled out of the
delivery mechanism of normal social
media the youtubes the twitters so on
and so forth like
milo yiannopoulos where the [ __ ] he
you know like what's milot i saw him
throw a half a million pound ring into
the coast of
hawaii a couple of weeks ago and i was
like milo you've been drinking
like that was but i haven't seen him for
ages i'm oh he's still got he's still
got a youtube account like
wow and he's then he's going through all
of this other sort of stuff but he would
have thought
traditionally if milo had gone through
something as big as that it would have
been
everywhere but you really can ex
communicado
you can take someone out of the public
zeitgeist
very easily with this and even if you
know let's say that
stephen's got all of every single one of
his four million or whatever it is how
many subs he's got on youtube huge
amount of subs
let's say all of those are part of his
private sites the mug club thing
that's now siloed that's it yes
shy of a very well incentive
incentivized referral scheme that
your audience and you think okay is this
it now i get to affect these people and
that's it
as everybody knows the way that the
delivery mechanisms on youtube work it's
not just the subscribers that see the
content
even if you don't think about the people
that view it it's 10 or 20x the
impressions
and even just seeing the content or
seeing the tweet even if you don't
decide to engage with it
counts for something in terms of moving
so i think
some political commentators specifically
on the right
because i think those guys tend to try
and silo themselves or create these um
fallback plans a little bit more as you
guys you guys have it as well right you
know just in case big tech decides to
come for you
i i think the the idea is fantastic and
it's obviously the only one that you
have
but i don't really think it's an
acceptable or a successful i don't think
anyone should see being cancelled and
still being able to exist and make a
good living
as a success because you are now taken
out
of the people that already subscribe to
your stuff they know
and mostly agree with the talking points
that you've got anyway yes they need to
be
educated and entertained but it i don't
think that should be classed as a
victory if people get cancelled like
that
this is something so few people
understand the
utility of youtube is not primarily
as a broadcast device it's a fine
broadcast system and you know there are
lots of broadcast systems and that
the utility of youtube is the ability of
discovery
right the fact that new people then are
going to find your stuff
so if you get booted out and let's say
you take your million person audience
with you or
your two million person audience with
you okay two million people
out and who knows how many of those will
remain active that's it that's all
you've got and
it will not grow and it will actually
shrink over time as people die and get
interested in other things and go away
and and uh so yes that's not a victory
at all
and the censorship and and the ostracism
is real i mean milo
yiannopoulos got truly canceled truly
unpersoned
and and now he's out of the public
discourse so
this again ties into the trap
conservatives
are reacting to cancel culture one of
two ways either they'll say you know
alex jones really did say some things
that are not good and that's okay i
think it was fine as long as it's just
alex and it's totally fine right so
those the squishes go along with it and
then the other way is we should never
cancel anybody
but there is a third option here which
is we should cancel
other people and i just think that this
middle idea we should never cancel
anybody is
has never existed anywhere all societies
have standards all societies have taboos
also when you transgress those they will
ostracize you
and this has been true in the furthest
animals of history all the way up until
the present
the question is what is the taboo who is
going to be ostracized in the 1940s and
50s
we prosecuted and ostracized many
communists this was uh colloquially
known as mccarthyism
but it wasn't just mccarthy i mean he
was one anti-communist senator but
there was the house committee on on
american activities there was the
hollywood blacklist
these were largely distinct institutions
and what it meant was if you were
advocating the overthrow of the united
states government the way of life
if you were actively supporting the
communist party which is
a front for the soviet union then you
were out you were cancelled and i think
that's a great thing
the difference is that in the 1950s you
were canceled if you were
a communist and today you are cancelled
if you are not a communist
and it's it you know if conservatives
understand this
and we say you know ostracizing people
who are
contrary to our understanding of the
world and our way of life you know
that's a fine thing what the what the
left will tell us and the squishes will
tell us is
well now you're no different than the
left but we are it actually is a
different thing to cancel communists as
it is to cancel
anti-communists and it's a different
thing to wave the hammer and sickle than
it is to wave
the american flag and i just think that
yes politics involves form it involves
certain you know
broad abstractions but it also involves
substance in particulars
what are you being cancelled for
that's not a very scalable solution is
it
it means that each individual
broad range each region of cancellations
needs to be looked at upon its own
merits that's going to be much more
effortful
that's going to be a challenge well it
requires
some kind of conservative unity so right
now you know
with the with the current cancel culture
which is exclusively leftist
we know the criteria it's if you say
anything
that can in any way be disingenuously
twisted and misinterpreted to to
be racist sexist homophobic
transphobic phobic phobic whatever you
know whatever the list goes on and on
if you in any way contradict the leftist
orthodoxies
you can be canceled
and uh and if they just don't like the
cut of your jib and you say any like i
think of my my daily wire colleague gina
carano
who who tweeted out something that was
anti-nazi
and the left interpret it it completely
flipped it on its head and said it was
pro-nazi or something that therefore you
know you could you could get rid of her
it's just because they didn't like her
because she was conservative
um so yes the left is unified and the
right is not
you know the paul ryan former speaker of
the house
who seems like a perfectly amiable
fellow is he's very much an economics
focused conservative and he really
doesn't seem to care very much about
cultural issues and he just gave a
speech the other day and he said you
know we got to stop talking about
how they're trying to trans the kids and
we got to stop talking about all these
cultural things which are just
distractions
we've got to talk about the only
important conservative issue
namely cutting taxes a little bit more
once again and i thought you know
pal you you obviously don't know what
time it is here
but that we have to deal with that
problem the only thing that has united
the right
since the fall of the berlin wall has
been
cutting taxes okay we can't agree on
anything else
and so if you if you can't agree on
anything else then you're absolutely
right
you're not going to be able to enforce a
set of standards so
i'm hoping now i think there is some
hope
you're seeing on the right the the
ascendancy
of much more traditional serious
conservatives i'm thinking of guys like
so rob amari at the new york post who
just wrote the unbroken threads for very
good book on this topic
guys like adrian vermeuel harvard law
professor really good on that topic
joram pazzone the the writer of virtue
of nationalism israeli philosophy is
really good patrick deneen why
liberalism failed i mean
this actually has really been emerging
this call for a substantive
conservative vision and so i hope that
we can get it but
are we there now absolutely not michael
knows ladies and gentlemen speechless
controlling words controlling minds
will be linked in the show notes below
where else should everyone go check out
your stuff
people can find me you can find all my
links at michaeljaynolds.com for now
but as you as you well know i'll
probably be booted off of social media
at some point certainly when the book
comes out so i just really i really i
want to thank you though
because it's been such a blast to talk
with you and i can't believe you
you are the first person in public to
have ever read
a book that i wrote with words so i'm
this is i'm very very
thrilled to be able to do it and i would
encourage everyone else to go get the
book my pleasure man thank you
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe it makes
me very happy
peace